prions l'été enfin on recherche pêcheurs
des douceurs crème glacée yo gourd
glaces et des sorbets sont les plaisirs
gustatifs par excellence on va la
crémerie ou à l'épicerie
mais on peut aussi en faire à la maison
et c'est pas très compliqué je trouve ça
très intéressant très plaisant de
pouvoir fermer crème glacée mais sorbet
moi même je choisi exactement les fruits
que je vais me mettre dedans les
produits que je mette dedans donc vais
chercher toutes la qualité que je veux
l'épicerie a testé deux fois plutôt
qu'une
4 sorbetière sans refroidisseur intégrer
toutes font crème glacée yo gourd
glacées et sorbets quatre modèles parmi
les moins chers entre 45 et 130 dollars
aujourd'hui l'objectif se détester ni
machines avec exactement la même recette
pour qu'on puisse comparer chacune des
machines basées sur un mélange qui est
standardisé donc on a fait une recette
de crème glacée est une recette de
sorbet des recettes qui sont facilement
cuisine à bhl à la maison bree
efficacité opérations et nettoyage
toutes ont assez bien performé tout
promettre des plaisirs glacés
prêts/emprunts minutes
certaines se vante de pouvoir faire un
produit en 15 minutes là mais ça me
surprendrait beaucoup donc sans prendre
vingt et trente minutes pour vraiment
chercher un beau produit avec une belle
onctuosité un foisonnement dans
lesquelles il ya beaucoup d'aires des
parlements des températures du
congélateur de prévoir du temps du mento
préparation qu'on met dans la cuve était
pas demande à température ambiante
le temps pour aller chercher le plus
beau sur b2 la poubelle classique peut
varier
donc il faut vraiment se fier à son
jugement
allez voir dans les machines la texture
de la machine et moi personnellement ce
que je fais aussi je prends la
température avec un thermomètre aussi
pour m'assurer que je vais chercher le
plus de fois possible dans les chambres
14 points
texture apparence égouts après trente à
quarante minutes sur binage et l'autre
les services où on y goûte avec le
maître glacier martin mahut picarde est
libre et on a terminé la même quantité
on voit qu'elles répondent pas le même
niveau fait qu il y en a qui ont eu plus
de foisonnement donc le cder
d'incorporer dans les crèmes glacées
donc ce règne - d'erding et quand même
onctueuse
oui il ya quand même plus penser au goût
des fois on a dit des petits moteurs un
peu plus dur
peut-être une fois congelés 2 on l'a
senti au plus la différence dans les
parties plus dur après le turbinage des
fabricants conseil de placer la crème
glacée au congélateur quelques temps
pour la laisser durcir
c'est ce qu'on a fait la clé du succès
c'est vraiment le froid le froid ya deux
façons de le contrôler c'est la cuve est
à température du mélange aussi que je
préparais pour mettre dans la cuve pour
faire mon sorbet ou fermer qu'à menacer
les recommandations varie de 8 à 24
heures pour le goût la texture et le
rendement
les quatre sortes de tiers ont bien
performé les différences se situent dans
les détails
le gros inconvénient de cette machine
note c'est l'orifice ici donc arriver
c'est assez petit pour venir mettre le
produit dedans et puis je la misère à
voir si ma texture que je vise et
atteindre tous pas donc ça c'est un
inconvénient la ville thing du produit
ici mais comme beaucoup de pièces mans
oui il ya beaucoup de morceaux
ce qui me préoccupe toujours ce savoir
est ce qu'un jour je vais perdre un
morceau est ce que je vais briser un
morceau cet avantage surtout l'ouverture
comme j'ai une grande ouverture je peux
plus facilement verser le produit dans
la cuve et j'ai un meilleur accès le
visionnement
c'est un appareil qui fonctionne très
bien moi j'ai pas trouvé de des foules
comme tel c'est un bon plastique mais il
me sens même temps ceux plus fragiles
que les cuisines à ces départs et la
note de rangement pour le film dans les
tests que j'ai fait il s'en met un petit
peu moins le performant en terme de
refroidissement
[Musique]
celui ci c'est le modèle le plus gros le
plus cher est ce que vaut le coup de
payer pour avoir un plus gros plus cher
alors je paye plus cher pour avoir
essentiellement une plus grande capacité
que je peux faire un petit peu plus de
produits d'une minuterie
moi personnellement je paye répond pour
le multi c'est vraiment nécessaire
[Musique]
et après avoir passé deux heures au
congélateur
on goûte à nouveau sa pas de l'air avoir
trop trop changer aisément tous que
c'est un peu plus ferme que tantôt ça
reste encore un peu mou la texture est
un peu plus de cristalliser frédéric
s'est aussi amusé à confectionner des
sorbets à la framboise un sort des ces
des fruits et du sucre et les quatre
appareils ont bien performé entre 45 et
130 dollars beaucoup différence de prix
est ce que la lune qui vous a séduit
davantage qu'il faut considérer c'est le
budget qu'on a ce qu'on veut en faire
dans le futur c'est quelque chose qu'on
veut utiliser sur une base de régulières
ou occasionnelles l'espace de rangement
colloque les quatre fonctionnent quand
même assez bien une île à peu près
toutes les machines sont capables de
faire un bon produit
la pression ça devient plus une
préférence de personnel mais je pense
que le meilleur rapport qualité prix
performance est vraiment la petite
cuisine c'est la façon dont ils
travaillent
l'entretien et la stabilité la
robustesse aussi une bonne machine
[Musique]